[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal sur tv et 78 nous sommes le
jeudi 11 janvier
les titres de cette édition c'est la
grand messe de la technologie et de
l'innovation le comte chômeurs
électronique seule chose se tient
jusqu'à demain à las vegas la french
tech qui est présenté les yvelinois bien
représentés elle nous serons en direct
dans un instant avec timothée le kent
ci-haut d'énergie skweres ils continuent
le combat les sept présidents des
conseils départementaux franciliens
donnait une conférence de presse ce
matin objectif contrer l es rumeurs à
propos de la métropole du grand paris et
qui laisse entendre notamment la
disparition du 92 93 et 94
chronique à suivre enfin un anniversaire
celui de la couveuse d'entreprises du bg
e yvelines qui fête ses 10 ans
600 entrepreneurs ont pu tester leur
projet clair mais les coachs
professionnels à villepreux et l'un
d'eux elle est notre invité avec
marie-dominique roseaux lee responsable
de la couveuse un petit rectificatif
avant de débuter ce journal recevions
hier pour rappel les deux auteurs du
livre la communauté une enquête sur
trappe nous vous annoncions dans ce
journal
une séance de dédicaces le 2 février à
la lie à la librairie le pavé dans la
mare à elancourt celle ci se déroulera
bien le 2 février mais organisé par la
librairie le pavé du canal à montigny le
bretonneux elle les infos sont à
retrouver sur le site internet de la
librairie avec près de 4000 exposants et
plus de 150 pays a représenté c'est le
plus grand salon a dédié à l'innovation
et la technologie le crs quand chômeurs
electronics show a débuté mardi à las
vegas c'est jusqu'à demain et plus de
300 entreprises françaises sont
présentes dont quelques yvelinois un
reportage de mélanie poker nicolas quere
lovitz et nicolas landry quatre jours
pour séduire et trois entreprises
yvelinoise le consumer electronics show
et le rendez vous international des
nouvelles technologies lamberth renora a
fait le voyage pour faire connaître son
gyropode aussi rencontrer
et rencontrer les bonnes personnes c'est
à dire que nous on cherche plutôt des
premiers clients des distributeurs parce
que si on veut attaquer par exemple le
marché américain
et puis combat des investisseurs qui
seraient intéressés au projet qui
voudraient rentrer etc
c'est un peu un peu large nous on est
dans une phase où on peut se permettre
de chercher après tout autre start-up la
société bélizienne oled comme son
produit là les filles une alternative au
wifi qui transmet des données par la
lumière
on a produit tous réalisés et prêt à
être commandés et livrés en juillet de
cette année la taxe sur sa position de
leader sur les marchés technologiques
on a eu une visite d'à peu près une
centaine de personnes
très vite les gens sont en général
renseigner sur la technologie c'est
vraiment des gentils sont soit ou de la
france dans les technologies une
troisième innovation yvelinoise est
présente à las vegas un chargeur sans
fil pensé par energy square 170 mille
visiteurs sont attendus pour ces crs
il fermera ses portes le 12 janvier et
nous avons justement en direct depuis
las vegas que sia d'énergie skweres il
est rambolitains timothée le kent
bonsoir plutôt bonjour ça d'ailleurs il
est neuf heures chez vous bonjour oui
merci d'être avec nous je disais si à
d'énergiques skweres à leur énergie
square développe une technologie de
recharge sans fil un domaine qui a la
cote d'ailleurs cette année au consumer
electronics show où beaucoup de
constructeurs présentent leurs
accessoires de recharge sans fil
c'est votre deuxième participation à ce
salon pourquoi faut-il y être alors au
cs on peut rechercher trois choses on
peut rechercher d'une part des contacts
presse parce qu'il ya à peu près toute
la presse mondiale qui est sur place et
qui vient un peu repérer des start up et
en parler on peut venir chercher des
distributeurs quand on a fini d'un dut
s'y réaliser des produits ensuite il
faut le vendre il faut des canaux de
distribution il ya tout un tas de
distributeurs internationaux et
américains qui vont un peu faire leurs
courses et repérer les futurs produits
oc us
et puis on peut y chercher des contacts
pour faire des affaires nous c'est pour
ça qu'on est donc trouver des fabricants
d'appareils électroniques par exemple
qui sont sur place et avec qui on peut
prendre contact et discuter facilement
on l'a dit juste avant sur le salon plus
de 300 entreprises et structures
françaises qui sont représentés au sein
de la french tech les jeunes pousses
françaises ont toute leur place dans ce
cms où elles ont toute leur place c'est
d'ailleurs c'est assez impressionnant de
voir d'alors dans eureka parc avec un
parc c'est l'endroit du crs qui est
destiné aux plus jeunes pousses aux
startups et la délégation française et
la seconde juste derrière les etats-unis
un peu plus de 2 100 startups qui sont
présentés donc ça parle français dans
toutes les allées et ont fait un certain
nombre de rencontres de français en plus
des rencontres d'américains et d'autres
d'autres personnes vous en avais dit de
moi à quoi ressemble finalement vos
journées depuis mardi sur ce crs 1 aux
journées donc là ça va être le troisième
jour du cs on a déjà fait deux jours
donc les journées c'est 9 heures 18
heures non-stop donc concrètement on est
debout on pitch donc on présente nos
produits à toutes les personnes qui
passent et c'est très dense il ya
vraiment des personnes s'enchaînent
rapidement on a des rencontres toutes
les 30 secondes toutes les minutes qui
arrive donc à la fin de la journée on
est on est assez fatigué alors certaines
innovations sont complémentaires avec la
bouche je rappelle que vous proposez une
technologie de rechargement de
téléphones et tablettes sans fil sa
technologie sans fil comment ça
fonctionne concrètement alors nous
contrairement à ce qui se fait sur le
marché qui fonctionne pas induction nous
on a une technologie qui fonctionne par
conduction leurs contacts et donc
concrètement ça permet de recharger
autant d'appareils qu'on veut sur un pad
qui fait à peu près 30 cm par 30
centimètres donc on peut charger 4,5
téléphone dessus et on travaille sur un
produit d'intégration qui est fait pour
être intégré directement dans des
meubles dans un bureau par exemple et
qui permet de recharger son ordinateur
portable simplement en le posant dessus
donc supprimé absolument tous les câbles
électriques et sur le développement en
ce moment où vous en êtes où il est
avancé ce développement de cette
technologie alors on a fini d'un disque
réalisé un premier produit qui est en
train d'être livré en ce moment qui est
le pad de recherche pour smartphones et
tablettes et on est en r&d sur le
chargeur d'ordinateurs portables qu'on
devrait sortir dans les prochaines
semaines dernière réaction quelle
réaction sur ce sur ce salon des des
participants d
financeurs qui peuvent venir vous voir
quelle réaction vous avez pu collecter
sur ce salon du cs alors nous on a des
très bonnes réactions surtout de la part
des fabricants d'appareils électroniques
qui cherchent des standards de charge et
qui veulent intégrer des technologies de
charge dans leurs appareils donc nous
c'est ce qu'on leur propose également
des bonnes réactions d'entreprises qui
ont tout un tas de smartphones ou
tablettes à charger tous les jours et
donc qui désirent acheter notre produit
pour ça pour plus avoir besoin de les
brancher en fin de journée et pouvoir
simplement les poser sur notre surface
et pour les charger on rappelle il vous
reste deux jours là sur place oui il
reste toujours là on va attaquer la
deuxième troisième journée dans quelques
minutes
et demain dernière journée merci à
timothée lequel d'avoir été avec nous
merci beaucoup depuis las vegas je
rappelle vous êtes le silo d'énergie
square et il rappelle aussi que vous
êtes rambolitains pour retrouver
quelques informations sur la technologie
que vous présentez sur ce s vous pouvez
vous rendre sur le site internet qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran et non c'est
non pour les départements d'île de
france ils se sont réunis une nouvelle
fois aujourd'hui à paris pour défendre
leur projet de métropole du grand paris
avec moi sur ce plateau nicolas
kirillovitch bonsoir bonsoir la
rédaction de tv 78 les sept départements
de la région hors capital s'inquiète des
décisions qui pourraient être annoncées
en février son départ du gouvernement
oui pour l'instant grégory ce n'est que
des suppositions il n'y a rien de
concret rien d'officiel mais les
présidents des départements d'île de
france ont lancé une campagne médiatique
très très active et c'est la preuve que
ces suppositions sont prises au sérieux
épreuve aussi de cette inquiétude tous
les présidents des départements parlent
d'une même voix que ce soit la droite
des hauts-de-seine où le parti
communiste du val de marne c'est assez
rare pour le souligner mais alors à quoi
s'opposent style concrètement me
direz-vous ils sont contre en fait le
projet de réforme de la métropole du
grand paris envisagé par le gouvernement
et donc par le président emmanuel macron
selon le
on a le monde cette réforme qui sera
précisée concrètement dans quelques
semaines prévoit la suppression des
trois départements de la petite couronne
92 93 et 94 au profit des établissements
publics territoriaux aussi appelé eux
péter créé il y a deux ans en même temps
que cette métropole c'est plus petites
structures qui sont au nombre de 11 dans
la petite couronne ressemble un
grossièrement à saint quentin en
yvelines et récupéré du coup toutes les
compétences des départements or pour les
présidents de ces départements cette
mesure serait inefficace qu'elle a car
elle irait en fait à l'encontre de cette
idée de simplification du millefeuille
territorial a lancé nicolas c'est pour
la petite couronne qu'en est il de la
grande couronne et donc des yvelines
pour les yvelines l'essonne le val
d'oise ou encore la seine-et-marne là il
n'y a pas de risque de suppression des
départements
mais tout simplement d'être exclu de la
métropole du grand paris de ne pas faire
partie du projet donc d'être en dehors
des possibles investissements du
développement de la région la grande
couronne veut faire partie de cette
métropole du grand paris concrètement
pierre bédier président du département
des yvelines nous résume sa position il
faut une région qui soit la métropole
métropole qui soit la région peu importe
l'île de france c'est une métropole et à
l'intérieur de cette métropole des élus
qui existe et des structures qui
existent que les départements donc la
métropole prend plus de pouvoir venant
de l'état c'est-à-dire du haut vers le
bas
venons aussi du bas vers le haut les
départements on peut transférer à la
métropole la métropole belle même
transférer des actions qu'elle n'arrive
pas à faire elles mêmes épreuves que le
sujet est sensible politiquement même
des député des yvelines de la république
en marche sont d'accord finalement avec
les départements même si ce n'est pas la
même couleur politique
c'est le cas de didier baichère député
de la 2e circonscription des yvelines
qui lui est favorable à une métropole
élargie à la région et à cette fusion
entre la métropole
du coup et la région et pourrait donc
éventuellement s'opposer au gouvernement
et à emmanuel macron mi février quand
les annonces seront faites
in fine est en résumé grégori tout le
monde est d'accord pour dire que cette
métropole du grand paris il faut la
réformer mais personne n'est d'accord en
revanche sur la méthode
tout ça ressemble à une guerre des
territoires entre paris métropole
actuelle et l'état d'un côté et puis en
face dans le camp opposé départements et
régions prochain épisode le 31 janvier
avec une nouvelle mobilisation prévue de
tous les départements une nouvelle fois
à paris ce sera le 31 janvier merci à
nicolas pour ces précisions
prendre trois minutes de plus pour
sauver une vie projets annoncés le 9
janvier par le premier ministre edouard
philippe la vitesse sur les routes
secondaires à double sens sans
séparateur central va baisser de 90 à 80
km heure face à cette mesure comment
réagissent les yvelinois et surtout les
professionnels un sujet signé à camille
lambert nicolas kirillovitch et patrick
jacques de dixmude
c'est pour ça que qui va empêcher les
actions
c'est pour la vitesse m'étonnerait ça
m'étonnerait que laura moye d'accès dans
la digue km ça m'étonnerait âgées trouve
à 80 kilomètres on peut avoir des
accédants à mort t elle mais bon auprès
des particuliers l'annoncent ne fait pas
l'unanimité le gouvernement a annoncé
mardi 9 janvier la baisse de la
limitation de 90 à 80 km heure sur les
routes secondaires sans séparateur
central
les professionnels de la route on peut
aussi appris la nouvelle
pour ce chauffeur de taxi il faut
surtout changer les mentalités
le taux d'accidentologie pour moi je
trouve que il a augmenté suite au
comportement des gens sur la route
donc nous en tant que professionnels de
la route on s'en rend bien le compte
bien sur la soie vous êtes sur une voie
vous êtes peut-être ça qu'on dit m en
dessous de la vitesse maximale
la personne derrière un constat partagé
par ce coursier qui travaille sur les
routes depuis 21 ans
pour lui le problème est avant tout
comportementale moi ce qui me fait peur
et ce que je remarque depuis un ou deux
ans et
c'est le téléphone portable je trouve
que c'est un véritable danger
je pense qu'une personne consciente qui
roulent à 90 en étant bien concentré sur
la route
je pense qu'elle est moins dangereuse
qu'une personne qui roule à 80 et qui
tapent des textos mais plus que le
téléphone l'alcool serait la première
cause de mortalité routière suivi par
les excès de vitesse depuis trois ans le
nombre de tués augmente en 2016 plus de
3400 personnes ont perdu la vie sur les
routes en ce début d'année 2010 8 il ya
bien sûr les nouveautés on vous en a
parlé dans ce set 8 journal il est aussi
les traditionnelles cérémonies de voeux
sans le voit dans un instant dans le
journal il y aussi les anniversaires la
couveuse d'entreprises du à bg evelyne
elle souffle c'est à sa dixième bougie
avec mon plateau deux invités pour en
parler
marie-dominique roseaux libon soir dans
ça vous est la responsable du dispositif
couveuse entreprises obg yvelines avec
nos également à claire mais là on soit
dans sa lettre coach professionnel
certifié à villepreux vous avez fait
partie de cette couveuse et cela vous a
aidé dans votre activité on va voir par
quel moyen
déjà marie dominique rose au lit à
l'occasion de ce dixième anniversaire du
de la couveuse du bg yvelines vous avez
publié ce calendrier il met en avant
douze histoires d'entrepreneurs qui
bénéficient ou encore ont bénéficié de
la couveuse dont c'est le cas pour
claire mais l'être
pourquoi les mettre en avant ces
entrepreneurs dans ce cas l'envié alors
d'idées c'était effectivement de mettre
en avant des parcours des personnes et
des femmes puisque la claire et une
femme qui a créé son entreprise
on avait envie après ses dix ans de
montrer qu'il était possible de créer
une entreprise qu'il y avait des
soutiens
bg hulene étant un organisme de conseil
de formation en soutien à la création
d'entreprise la couveuse et un des
dispositifs que nous proposons et qui
permet donc de tester pendant une année
son projet avant de s'immatriculer donc
l'idée c'était à la fois de mettre en
avant ses porteurs de projets et puis
aussi des partenaires qui nous aident
dans la constitution de la couveuse et
dans son financement
les dix ans pour cette couveuse on l'a
dit création en 2007 600 porteurs de
projets ont été accompagnés par ce
dispositif vous en avez dit deux mots
les objectifs d'une couveuse
concrètement alors très concrètement des
objectifs c'est on arrive avec un projet
mature donc un projet mature ça veut
dire qu'on a dépassé le stade de l'idée
on sait ce que l'on va vendre et à qui
on va le vendre
pour autant on a encore des doutes des
questionnements sur la façon dont ça va
se passer et notamment sur une question
qui nous semble importante qui est celle
de je vais devenir un chef d'entreprise
et ça c'est un nouveau métier
est ce que je suis en capacité de
devenir ce chef d'entreprise que j'ai
envie de devenir c'est primordial mais
avant cette immatriculation de pouvoir
tester de pouvoir y exercer ce projet au
sein de la couveuse
ou alors primordial le mot est peut-être
fort mais ce qui est intéressant c'est
que si on a envie
si on le souhaite et si on a envie
d'être formés à former à ce métier de
chef d'entreprise c'est possible et
c'est possible via la couveuse et vous
proposer du coup grâce à cette coureuse
un accompagnement voilà donc
l'accompagnement et d'y renforcer
puisque les personnes sont à la fois
accompagné en individuel très
concrètement il le bénéficie de rendez
vous avec un conseiller expert alors une
à deux fois par mois en fonction du
projet on trouve ce en fonction du
profil et en parallèle toute une série
de formations 15 formations qui va
permettre à la personne de monter en
compétences alors j'allais parler des
formations mais c'était peut-être votre
question moi je voulais vous relancez
sur les sorties positives 80 % de
sorties positives mais c'est un
dispositif qui marche bien alors c'est
un dispositif peut dire qui cartonne je
peux me permettre ce en début d'année
donc il faut donc effectivement 83% de
sortie positif chaque année qui sont
dispatchés en 65 % de création effective
donc vraiment des gens qui créent leur
activité à peu près entre 10 et 15 % de
personnes qui vont choisir de poursuivre
leurs activités avec une société de
portage ou une coopérative d'activités
et d'emploi
une dizaine de courses
qui va retourner à l'emploi parce que le
test n'est pas concluant ou parce que
tout simplement ils s'aperçoivent que
finalement le salariat c'est aussi
intéressant donc on est on est assez
fiers effectivement de s'auto de sortie
positif d'autant plus quand on s'adresse
à des personnes qui sont demandeurs
d'emploi et comme vous l'avez peut-être
vu dans le calendrier à une majorité de
femmes beaucoup de femmes j'allais vous
lancez là-dessus justement il ya un
intérêt particulier aussi pour l'épauler
femme alors c'est pas forcément voulu
mais il s'avère que les femmes sont très
présentes
dans notre couveuse c'est aussi vrai
régionalement mais mais dans le
département des yvelines ça reste un
pourcentage exceptionnelle puisque
chaque année on tourne autour de 80 % de
femmes qui rentre dans le dispositif est
donc on voit que basse et femmes créé
leur activité vivre de leur activité
développent leurs activités et ont des
parcours exceptionnel donc ça nous met
évidemment le baume au coeur de les
mettre en avant l'une de ces femmes
justement que l'armée allait parler de
votre parcours vous avez travaillé
d'abord dans les ressources humaines
avant de changer de voie de vous tourner
vers le le coaching finalement comment
l'opportunité d'intégrer la couveuse
s'est elle présentée
comment ça commence à ces faits alors
effectivement l'opportunité s'est
présentée auprès d'une autre personne
qui était coach qui avait été la
formation avec moi et qui m'a parlé de
cette de cette structure en fait pour
être accompagné était sur l'île
elle s'était fait accompagner par la
structure et avait lancé son activité
grâce à l'accompagnement moi en tant que
coach c'est vrai que je ne peux pas
chercher quelques quelque chose de plus
alignée on va dire avec ce que je
propose qui est de me faire moi même
accompagnés donc ça a été naturel
d'aller postuler puisque on postule à la
couveuse toile on ne peut pas entendre
ouais tout à fait rentrer comme ça et
c'était aussi pour moi un gage de un
gage de sérieux que d'avoir à présenter
un dossier et rien dans le fait de
préparer ce dossier ça m'a déjà mis le
pied à l'étrier pour me lancer
quand où et quand on change de voix on
se remet finalement en question le fait
qu' un accompagnement
c'est quelque chose d'important à tout à
fait tout à fait ça a été pour moi comme
un comme un top départ en fait parce que
comme marie dominique la dia à la fin un
accompagnement individuel un
accompagnement collectif et qu'on va se
retrouver entre porteurs de projets et
puis il ya aussi justement tout ce
réseau duquel on peut bénéficier puisque
on va se retrouver une deux fois par
mois avec une quinzaine de personnes à
chaque formation ça peut être des
personnes différentes donc mois sur
l'année j'ai dû rencontrer une
cinquantaine de personnes et je suis
toujours en contact et voir je travaille
maintenant avec
avec certains d'entre elles certains
d'entre eux et elles des hommes à part
une année passée ouais ça va ressembler
à quoi concrètement oulédi
accompagnement des rencontres tout au
long de cette année peut-être very close
tout à fait alors il y avait quasiment
une formation par mois donc c'est sur la
forme d'une journée une journée entière
le midi on déjeune ensemble donc ça
permet aussi de créer un peu liens de
convivialité
quand aussi de parler de nos projets et
de se référencer mutuellement auprès de
auprès de notre entourage auprès de nos
proches ensuite un rendez vous par mois
avec la conseillère particulière là
c'est vraiment du coaching là moi j'ai
beaucoup apprécié le le face à face avec
ma conseillère et qui était très qui
s'adaptait beaucoup à ce que chacun
pouvait lui demander et moi ça m'a servi
notamment à avoir plein d'idées que
j'aimerais jamais eu comme par exemple
d'aller faire des partenariats avec la
mairie de la ville où avec d'autres
personnes auxquelles je n'arrive pas à
penser vous vivez aujourd'hui de votre
activité fait vous diriez ça apporte et
oui c'est ça une part importante la
couveuse dans le fait que ça fonctionne
aujourd'hui je pense que oui oui tout
simplement pour la structure déjà mettre
en place moi je j'adore le coaching
j'adore l'accompagnement par contre le
côté juridique comptable et financier
c'est pas mon fort et le fait d'avoir
régulièrement des points et d'être suivi
sur ces niveaux là pour moi ça a été
vraiment un gage de stabilité de
sécurité pour démarrer on a aussi un
logiciel de comptabilité et de gestion
sur lequel ont saisi toutes nos factures
on apprend à comme disait marie
dominique à être entrepris un
entrepreneur chef d'entreprise
et puis a géré ça sa comptabilité et
c'est un gros plus de savoir qu'on est
soutenue là dessus et qu'on n'est pas
tout seul il nous reste un peu plus
d'une minute marie dominique rose ollier
concrètement comment un tel retour
comment peut-on intégrer cette couveuse
d'entreprises alors pour les personnes
intéressées rien de plus simple vous
pouvez aller sur le site de bg huit
villes ina.fr des jeux soit 1,18 point
fr vous aurez tout un tas d'informations
sur le dispositif et vous participerez à
une réunion d'information collective
à partir de là si le dispositif vous
intéresse
vous allez renseigner le fameux
autodiagnostic dont parlait tout à
l'heure claire qui nous permet en fait
de comprendre où vous en êtes sur votre
projet et puis vous rencontrerez un
conseiller en individuel qui vous
préparera à ce fameux comité d'admission
le comité d'admission qui valide
l'intégration à dans la course merci à
vous d'avoir été avec moi sur ce plateau
marie dominique rose au lit un
responsable du dispositif couveuse
d'entreprises aux babys nés merci
également à claire mais les coachs
professionnels certifiés vous êtes
établi à villepreux et pour plus
d'informations sur cette couveuse
d'entreprises du bg yvelines vous pouvez
vous rendre sur le site internet qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran politique
locale le torchon brûle à maurepas un
ancien élu de la ville a porté plainte
pour diffamation contre le maire les
républicains à grégory gary astier ainsi
que de a demandé membres de sa majorité
tous trois ont été mises en examen
qualification automatique dans ce
domaine de la part du parquet l'ex élu
qui garde l'anonymat a dit avoir été
victime d' insulte sur les réseaux
sociaux affaire qui traduit à l'actuel
climat délétère au sein du conseil
municipal dans le journal de la ville de
décembre les tribunes politiques ont
daigné ont donné lieu pardon à de
véritable passe d'armes entre la
majorité et l'opposition controverse
également à coignières autour du pmu le
plan local d'urbanisme arrêté du arrêté
par le conseil municipal le 19 décembre
dernier ce projet qui planifient à
l'évolution de la commune rencontre des
oppositions des oppositions auprès de
certains habitants du quartier du conte
chevreuse les précisions
avec ce reportage de nicolas landresse
donc là vous voyez la parcelle sur
laquelle j'ai déposé un permis de
construire
résidente à coignières depuis 41 ans
christina mort et souhaite construire
cette maison
problème la mairie d'auch coignard a
rendu un sursis à statuer sur cette
demande
en clair la municipalité se donne le
droit de décider ultérieurement
de leur côté l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines et le préfet ont
donné un avis favorable
j'ai acheté ce terrain que je dois
aujourd'hui j'ai un prêt sur de
nombreuses années je l'achetais
constructibles et
le p lus laurent inconstructibles
conseillère municipale opposés au plan
local d'urbanisme christina mort et a
été contrainte de quitter la majorité
communale le pmu compétence de la ville
déterminent l'évolution de la ville le
quartier du pont de chevreuse est
concerné par cette planification
l'objectif du pays et lui est de rendre
inconstructibles l'intérieur des
terrains en coeur d'îlot en fait donc
c'est ce qu'on vend en pointillés tout
ça ça reste avant sauf tible les
opposants se sont organisés en
association des riverains du pont de
chevreuse
face à la contestation la mairie se
défend sur les orientations du plan
local d'urbanisme
c'est un plan local d'urbanisme qui a
notamment pour orientation d'autres
orientations bien sûr mais notamment
comme orientation de mettre en valeur
l'environnement est également de
conserver la qualité du cadre de vie de
la ville de coignières nous souhaitons
conserver sur ce quartier plus
particulièrement du pan de chevreuse une
qualité de vie c'est un quartier qui est
peu dense et je pense qu'il faut
conserver cette qualité de vie ce projet
a été arrêté lors du dernier conseil
municipal le 19 décembre dernier
de son côté christine à mort et a lancé
une procédure contentieuse devant le
tribunal administratif contre la
décision de la commune et puis les
cérémonies de voeux se poursuivent à
saint quentin en yvelines hier plaisir
souhaitait une bonne année à ses
habitants présence notamment du
président du sénat gérard larcher
c'était au gymnase nicholas l'heure lors
de la soirée la ville s'est vu remettre
le label ville conviviale ville
solidaire 2018 pour son action en faveur
du mieux vivre ensemble est distinction
accordée par la fédération européenne
des solidarités de proximité
dans son allocution la mère joséphine
coleman ce berger a précisé les grands
axes de plaisir pour 2018 est résolument
tournée vers le sport et la voirie
propos recueillis par camille lambert
on a vraiment des grands projets au
niveau sportif
par rapport par rapport aux aménagements
des parcours sportifs sur le parc du
château également n'en parle des quatre
saisons on a aussi énormément de
développement de voirie sur la ville de
plaisir sur trois endroits
particulièrement au quartier de la
boissière très important sur la mare au
sol très important aussi et sur la
finition de la venue des sablons voilà
c'est la fin de ce set 8 journal replay
sur notre site internet et notre
application mobile tv 78 on se quitte
sur un hommage une chanson et un clip
pour ne pas oublier les victimes des
attentats la marche décrions c'est une
chanson écrite en 2015 par marquez a qu
un habitant de maurepas auteur et
compositeur il a été inspiré par la
marge du 11 janvier 2015
rappelez vous la france est l'arrêt
francs en france et à travers le monde
et des millions de personnes s'étaient
rassemblées on se quitte en musique
excellente soirée sur tv 78 des mois
pour écouter les gens
à
la fin
[Musique]